[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god welcome to bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
one of the most ingenious and daring
escapes ever achieved
took place in 1979
two families with eight members in total
escaped the oppressive country of
communist east germany by crossing the
border to west germany in a homemade hot
air balloon after two previous failed
attempts and near capture the determined
strelsak and witsel families tried again
on september 16 the four adults and four
children wedged into a 15 square foot
steel and rope basket
using a homemade flame thrower they
filled a balloon that they had secretly
made on a sewing machine with about
1435 square yards of different colored
fabric
at two in the morning with a glowing
balloon towering a hundred feet above
them the gondola rose above east germany
and it drifted for 11 miles in 30
minutes
carrying the family over the iron
curtain to freedom where they safely
touched down in west germany's barvaria
you know the bible tells of another
eight people that floated to freedom
stay with us and we're going to learn
more on this edition of bible answers
live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
hi listening friends welcome to bible
answers live and if you've got any bible
questions that's a free phone call that
number is 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
we are also streaming the program and
soon we're going to be on some network
stations we're just these are pilot
programs that were we've just recently
moved into our new studio you want to
see what it looks like you can go to the
doug batchelor facebook page or the
amazing facts facebook page and you'll
see uh the studio as it unfolds and
comes together my name is doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
friends and pastor as we always do let's
start the program with prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
opportunity to open up your word and
study together and father we recognize
the bible is your book
in order for us to correctly understand
it we need the holy spirit so we ask the
holy spirit to be with us here in the
studio and be with those who are
listening wherever they might be
in their car or at home we just pray for
your blessing in jesus name amen amen my
past today you opened the program
talking about an amazing escape it's
always exciting to read about the
commitment and the hard work of people
wanting freedom and uh finally families
working together i understand there were
situations where
they were sort of on the radar screen of
the authorities they began to suspect
something and so they had to uh sew this
body balloon in secret and they were
able to bring fabric together it was
just an incredible feat but it worked
for them they actually floated over to
uh west germany yeah and just the the
commitment and the the danger not only
the danger of possibly being caught and
in prison but the danger of dying
i mean at one point their balloon caught
on fire when they were igniting and they
had to calmly put it out with a fire
extinguisher
so um yeah it's just an amazing story
and it's obvious that they had some
divine help
in getting across the border but when i
thought about those eight people
floating to freedom it made me think
about a time in the bible you can read
in first peter chapter 3 verse 20.
when once the divine longsuffering
waited in the days of noah
while the ark was being prepared in
which a few that is eight souls were
saved through water
they didn't float upon the air they
floated up on the water you can read in
genesis 7 17 the flood continued 40 days
on the earth the waters increased and
bore up the ark and it rose high above
the earth until ultimately those waters
covered the highest mountains you know
the bible tells us in the book of
matthew jesus is giving some prophecies
about the second coming and he says in
matthew chapter 24 thank you you can
read in verse 37
but as the days of noah were
so also will the coming of the son of
man be
for as in the days before the flood they
were eating and drinking and marrying
and given in marriage until the day that
noah entered the ark and they did not
know until the flood came and took them
all away
so will the coming of the son of man be
talks about how the world has become so
preoccupied with a selfish pursuits
and earthly pursuits nobody was thinking
about god
that the the flood kind of took them all
by surprise
and jesus said it's going to be that way
again just before the second coming
and we're seeing that in the world today
not only did jesus say it would be like
the days of noah in luke chapter 17 he
says is also going to be like the days
of lot
and the you know the immorality and the
perversion
and that you see back in the story of
lot is going to be replicated in the
last days and and i think we're seeing
that prophecy fulfilled right now
so um
how do you get ready for
the bible says the world will not be
destroyed next time with a flood but
it's going to be a fire
how do you survive that we've got a free
offer that talks about how to be rescued
from that calamity our study guide is
entitled rescue from above and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks it's a free phone call the
number of call is 800 835 800-835-6747
and you can ask for our amazing facts
study guide it's entitled rescue from
above we'll send it to you for free if
you're outside of north america we
encourage you to take a look at our
website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the study
guide right there again it's called
rescue from above
we'll be ready to go to the phone lines
we've got our first caller this evening
we've got george listening from new new
jersey or north jersey george welcome to
the program
yes north jersey where we've had a lot
of snow lately you know what i mean
yeah
and thanks for calling yes good evening
pastors yeah i was looking at isaiah uh
reading some of isaiah chapter two the
first four verses of that chapter talks
about something to pass in the latter
days
and uh
it kind of seems like it's talking about
the new earth but then it says latter
days
so i wonder how you would interpret that
i know
some pre-millennialists who believe that
the reign of christ is on the earth
would interpret that as the millennial
age you know but i know you don't teach
that or believe that and isaiah has a
lot of i've asked some questions before
uh
to you about isaiah that's some passages
seem very difficult at times you know as
to when they take place right so if you
can enlighten me on that on those first
four verses of second chapter of isaiah
okay well for our friends listening
george i'm going to read a few of those
verses we always know that
a lot of our folks are kind of working
or cooking in the kitchen and when i
left home karen was cooking up a storm
and sometimes they're driving down the
road so we want to just read this the
word that isaiah the son of amos saw
concerning judah and jerusalem now will
come to pass in the latter days that the
mountain of the lord's house will be
established on the top of the mountains
and shall be exalted above the hills and
all nations shall flow to it and many
people shall come and say come let us go
up to the mountain of the lord to the
house of the god of jacob he will teach
us his ways and we will walk in his
paths for out of zion
shall go forth the law and the word of
the lord from jerusalem well let's just
pause right there for a minute now
isaiah i think is giving what you would
call a dual prophecy here
first of all
during the time of christ with the
ministry of christ
the message of truth
was not just for the jews it was for all
nations and so this is a prophecy that
when it talks about all nations flowing
to the house of the lord when jesus
walked out of the temple he said your
house has left you desolate
and the earthly sanctuary was ultimately
destroyed
christ had destroyed this temple made
with hands i will make one without hands
and he spoke of his body the church
after the outpouring of the holy spirit
christ began to build up another
spiritual house peter said we are living
stones in that house ephesians chapter 2
says we are being built up in into a
house a dwelling place for god and so
this was in part a prophecy that now the
gospel the pure gospel about jesus
would be exalted where all nations could
see it and they would flow to it so
there's a there's a spiritual analogy
there but quite literally at the end of
the millennium
when god brings a new jerusalem down to
earth
and all the wicked are destroyed
the knowledge of the lord will cover the
earth the bible says and isaiah says
that actually
and all people will flow unto
god
and it tells us that the lord god is the
temple in it and so
i i think this prophecy will literally
be fulfilled when the kingdom of god
fills the earth and
people from every tribe and nation that
are have accepted christ will flow to
the lord
any thoughts on that yes some of these
prophecies seem to be
spiritual then literal right they seem
to be a combined thing sometimes yeah
there's several places you'll find what
they call a dual prophecy let me give
you a quick example because this comes
up sometimes
in matthew 24 the disciples come to
jesus and they said
when will this be the destruction of
jerusalem
and the destruction of the temple and
the second coming and he combines his
whole answer into one
soliloquy he gives there in matthew 24
and mark 13.
part of it's talking about when the
temple would be destroyed by the romans
but it's a dual prophecy that talks
about a final assault on god's people
before the second coming
so
you've got several examples of these
dual prophecies in the bible well i hope
that helps a little bit george
appreciate your calling in and uh
probably ought to head to another caller
okay we got amanda listening from texas
amanda welcome to the program hi thank
you
thank you for calling yes um well my
question is about the description of
jesus in revelation
chapter 1 verse 14-15 um
but
the description
of him in the bible is totally different
from the portrait that people have of
him wouldn't that be deceiving everybody
well what description in the bible you
mean this one
um
it's in revelation right yeah this is a
description of christ in heaven
i don't think it's telling us exactly
what jesus looked like on earth
um where's the prophecy pastor ross in
daniel where it also says
uh i saw his uh though it kind of
describes the lord
and
i think maybe daniel 7
is another description of jesus or god
anyway
and it describes god in this glorified
state
but um
i i don't know if that's telling us you
know he was six feet tall and he had
brown eyes or blue eyes or anything like
that i think the verse you're referring
to is daniel chapter 10 verse six again
a very similar description that you find
in revelation 114 talks about eyes as
flames of fire and feet like burial or
or brass
in the fire
of course this is a symbolic
representation of jesus here you've got
a picture of a sword coming out of his
mouth the sharp two-inch sword well that
of course is symbolic revelation is a
symbolic book so i don't think you can
take the description that you find in
revelation chapter one and say well
that's that's exactly what jesus looks
like now in heaven there's a lot of
symbolism in the book of revelation
yeah so amanda when it talks about the
sword coming out of jesus mouth
you probably will understand that's
a symbol because the bible says the word
of god is sharper than any two-edged
sword so we know that jesus has the word
in his mouth his eyes are like a flame
of fire because he sees and knows all
things
it says his hair is like pure wool
because it says our sins will be whiter
than wool he's pure
and so i think there's a lot of
analogies in the description but he will
be visible and he will be a glorious
being when we see him in the second
coming you know one of the big mysteries
there's only one very dubious
description physical description of
jesus in history and it's probably it's
what they call an apocryphal writing
meaning that you know somebody probably
manufactured it but it's supposed to be
the description of a roman soldier that
he gave of jesus but it's it's and
that's where i think a lot of artists
get this conception of he's got you know
hazel air hair and and brown eyes and
he's uh you know six feet tall or medium
build and
yeah i don't think we can count on that
so would it be wrong to even have that
portrait
because that's what a lot of people go
to is that portrait
yeah you know it's there's a risk as i
travel around the world not sure this is
true with pastor ross when i go to india
it's very interesting they have a very
indian
picture of jesus and you see it in the
artwork there the indian christians and
when i go to africa i see a more african
uh picture of jesus
and when i go to the pacific islands i
see a more polynesian description of
jesus so everyone sort of you know
superimposes some of their ideas on what
they think jesus looks like but we've
got to be careful with those pictures
because the bible warns us against
idolatry which could be a statue it
could be a picture yeah
yeah in deuteronomy right yeah well in
exodus and deuteronomy and even
revelation guard against idols and
images yeah okay well i hope that helps
a little bit hey we thank you very much
amanda and um
yeah we gotta
keep in mind that god is more glorious
than anything we can imagine
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time call us at 1 800
god says
[Music]
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling
1-844-215-7000 that's 1-844-215-7000
all right we've got noah listening in
illinois noah welcome to bible answers
live thanks for having me doug and uh
gene
my question is how come you never really
see any wedding ceremonies in the old
testament
for example when jacob married rebecca
or
isaac got married
yeah well you you do see a wedding
ceremony and not so much the ceremony
but you know there yeah i guess it's a
wedding ceremony with jacob and leah
talks about the days of the wedding
feast
and you don't see one with isaac isaac's
a very unusual account where it tells us
that basically abraham contracted for a
wife
he sent the dowry eliezer picked up a
rebecca from
the land of haran brought her back
isaac knew his wife was in route and
when he met her says he took her to his
mother's tent of course at that point
his father is like 140 years old because
isaac was
40 when he got married so abraham's got
to be 140 years old so he didn't have a
big celebration i don't know
that says he took her to his mother's
tent and she became his wife but with
jacob there is a wedding ceremony and
then you get to the book judges it talks
about the wedding ceremony of samson and
there's some others
but um
get some very interesting wedding
ceremonies after the benjamites were
destroyed where the girls went out
dancing and the men captured their wives
i'd say
yeah it's that's pretty primitive but um
i don't know if we're answering your
question noah
you answered it i just wanted to know
like how like
i didn't think that there was wedding
ceremonies in the old testament
well we in it pastor ross might find it
but talks about a a seven-day wedding
feast for jacob when he married leah
he was supposed to marry rachel but his
father pulled a switchy rooney on him at
the last minute and he ended up marrying
leah and then he had to
he had to end up marrying rachel too and
then he got their handmaids he got four
for the price of one you might say
you're looking that up okay so that's
yeah that's in genesis uh yeah genesis
29 talks about the the wedding and uh
how that
yeah jacob was deceived he was expecting
the other sister he got i got to talk to
him about that one
i'll take him off by himself and have a
little chat and say how is it you did
not know that was leah until the morning
all right all right we've got jordan
listening in tennessee jordan welcome to
the program
hi
hey thanks for calling and your question
um i was reading in matthew chapter 13
verses three through nine about the
seeds i don't understand the parable
that is talking about
matthew 13 and uh this is it starts when
he said um a sower went out to sow yes
and he sowed some seeds
is there a part of it you do not
understand because jesus actually
explains it
a little later in in the same chapter
yes i know but i am have miles cp and
from four years deletion and i'm really
slow learning things okay and i have a
king james bible and it's kind of really
hard to read to me well let me see if i
can help you a little bit
here jesus tells about a man who's
sowing seeds
and the seeds when they threw seeds out
in bible time they would do what they
call broadcast and they quite literally
would reach into a bag of seeds they'd
walk through the field and they'd cast
their arm in a big sweeping motion karen
and i did this last week with poppy
seeds out behind our office
and it's just a primitive way of
broadcasting well some of the seeds you
can't control where every seed lands
some seeds fell on good soil some seeds
fell on rocky ground some seeds fell on
the
shallow ground and some seeds fell on
the path
and he said that you know the birds came
and got the seeds that fell on the path
the seeds that fell on the shallow
ground that was full of rocks
it um
it sprang up but because it didn't have
any depth as soon as it got warm it died
out some of the seeds fell among the
weeds
and the thorns choked so they didn't
they had to compete with the vegetation
and they kind of died off and then some
seeds fell on good soil and they were
very productive
and then christ explains that the seeds
that are snatched away by the ravens or
the birds that means when someone hears
the word of god the seed is the word of
god
someone first hears the word of god
sometimes the devil will snatch it away
and distract them and keep them from
really even paying attention to it and
when the seeds fall among the
the thorns the cares of this life choke
it out they get too worried about well
you know how am i going to serve god and
they worry so much about
making money and their job and the other
personal needs of life
and then when it says some seed has
shallow ground it doesn't put down roots
uh they don't nurture it and uh when
they hear the word of god they don't
read they don't pray and it just doesn't
really even take root
so this is the way that different people
respond when they hear the bible
preached
and
hopefully that helps a little bit jordan
and we appreciate your calling in with
your question tonight
all right we've got jerry listening in
oregon jerry welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors
basically i have a lifelong friend who
has been a good person but he's never
made a christian commitment
he was diagnosed with
bone cancer recently and he's going to
go into
hospice shortly
and he's finally
verbally to me acknowledge the lord
and he lives 300 miles away no church
affiliation i'll be visiting him
but i don't know what to do about the
baptism issue
again bone cancers you know can be
extremely painful usually they're highly
sedated
no i understand my mother died from bone
cancer
um well you know if you have a chance to
visit with him and he's still lucid
uh it's wonderful that he has
opened his mind to god
don't be afraid to ask him
just in the simplest terms
does he believe that god first of all he
knows he's sinned
does he believe the promise of god that
god sent jesus in the world to suffer
for the sins of the world and that would
include the sins of your friend
and if he acknowledges that he believes
that
um then say have you asked
god to forgive your sins
for christ's sake will you accept that
jesus died for your sins
and
be optimistic that he'll say yes and
then say well let's ask him right now
i'm sure he will yeah and pray with him
and just say
you might even ask him say you know can
you repeat after me dear lord i know i'm
a sinner i'm sorry for my sins i repent
i accept jesus sacrifice in my behalf
and just you know you'll even find
online
some very simple uh outlines of
biblically how do you lead a person to
christ and it's a very simple um
it's a choice that you can make and you
can help him with that choice you don't
have to be a pastor he doesn't have to
be baptized if if he can't be baptized
you can tell him jesus will give him
credit for his baptism christ was
baptized he never sinned
he can get credit for jesus baptism
so don't let that be an obstacle to his
having peace in his final hours that god
will forgive his sins
well okay then
uh
i'm without sounding haughty i've got a
fair
biblical knowledge and i'm a christian
but he expresses desire
would i
should i do this and for example in a
bathtub if he
feels he can physically do manage if if
if the hospital or his circumstances
will accommodate that
i actually i went to one lady who was
felt very strongly she wanted to be
baptized she was also dying from a lung
cancer in this case
and she said can we use my bathtub i
said absolutely and she at that point
had
she kind of wasted away where she was
only about 90 pounds and her son lifted
her up put her in the bathtub and i
baptized her
and
she just came out just smiling and and
felt great peace at that so you can do
that
um i don't think baptism will be an
obstacle to their salvation if they're
you know on their deathbed
um you know some people well
but if it'll give him peace and you can
do it then by all means
maybe i shouldn't use the word death bed
but
he's he's been told basically he has
between three weeks and three months
and as you know he's going to be
most likely being morphine or fentanyl
or one of those
yeah could be on a lot of pain well you
know even even when you're under the
influence uh i've talked to people who
are on morphine and they can still
understand
uh so
i'll pray that god gives you wisdom
jerry that's wonderful you're going to
go see your friend and and maybe in his
closing earthly days you can be a source
of great encouragement and peace for him
and we we pray that's the case
all right thank you for your call jerry
we've got uh faith listening in texas
faith welcome to the program
hi
hey you got a great name hi faith hi um
my question is what's the difference
between murder and kill okay good
question
now if you if you have a mosquito biting
you on the arm and you slap him you will
not be arrested by the police for murder
murder is a crime where you take away an
innocent human life
if a soldier
goes to war and he's ordered to defend
his country and sometimes in doing that
he has to shoot the enemy
that soldier will never be accused of
murder
and if a policeman is protecting people
who are being robbed and he has to shoot
someone and they die
it is killing but it's not murder now
the ten commandment says thou shalt do
no murder i know it says in the
in king james it's translated thou shalt
not kill but
technically it actually says thou shalt
do no murder and when jesus quotes that
commandment in the new testament he does
say it that way he says you shall not
murder
we're not to take innocent human life
and so that's the difference you know um
you know every time you pull a weed
you're killing something technically
yeah yeah does that help at all
yes okay you're not thinking about
murdering anyone are you
no okay good just making sure
all right hey well we're really thankful
you called in faith appreciate that you
have a good night and by the way you're
about 10 years old we have a special
series of study guides pastor ross and i
did both video and lessons
called amazing adventure you can just
type in amazing adventure in google
and it will take you to the amazing
facts bible study series and we think
you'd really enjoy that faith if you've
not already seen it
thank you for your call we've got uh
next caller from new jersey java java
welcome to the program
thank you very much
uh i have a conflict
over the passage
the heavens belong to god
and the earth is given to man
and
the conflict seems to be growing greater
with all the explorations into space
yeah
well first of all what verse are you
talking about because i don't know that
passage in the bible oh it isn't it's in
the old testament do you know where
yes i do
it's a very well-known verse
thank you very much sir okay didn't mean
to put you on the spot but i i haven't
heard that verse before
i mean it does say that you know god
made the heavens and the earth in
genesis
but i don't remember the part where it
says that uh you know the heavens belong
to god but the earth belongs to man
it does say that god gave adam dominion
over the earth so i was just wanting to
make sure before i answered
exactly what verse she was referring to
sometimes people hear part of a verse
and part of a saying from culture and
they think it's in the bible but
it's not
friends that's why we're here we're
going to try and answer more bible
questions in just a minute don't go
anywhere we're coming back you can still
call in with your questions 800 god says
and we're back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
written by the hand of god
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
get pastor doug batchelor's 12-part
sermon series on the 10 commandments by
calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
millions of people believe that planet
earth is on the verge of some apocalypse
that will plunge the world cities into
chaos
in response
thinking people everywhere are wondering
if it might be a good time to locate
their families outside of the congested
metropolitan areas
in my new book heading for the hills a
beginner's guide to country living i do
my best to provide a biblical balance
i'd like to share with you some of the
crucial things you'll need to know
before you head up for the hills
i'd also like to identify some of the
practical things you look for in buying
a piece of country land how to develop
water power and a garden all while still
seeking to save the lost this book has
some very valuable information for
anybody that's ever considering country
living order your copy of heading for
the hills call 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 pm
and 8 p.m pacific time to receive any of
the bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
we are back listening friends thank you
for staying with us and if you have a
bible question the number to call in
with your question is 800-463-7297
and that's 800 god says we are streaming
on facebook you can watch the program
right now and listen by going to the
amazing facts facebook page or the doug
batchelor facebook page and i am doug
batchelor my name is john ross and we've
got some colas lined up pasta dough so
we go to the next one we have martin
listening from michigan martin welcome
to the program
thank you
i have a bible verse that i want to
understand better it's second
corinthians 3 3
for as much as ye are manifestly
declared to be the epistle of christ
thus writ not with the ink but with the
spirit of the living god
not tables of stone but in fleshly
tables of the heart
when i read this bible verse pastors i
started writing the letter to god
and i have about 10 pages so far
so you want me to share with you what we
think that verse means
i i the way i understood it it was like
telling me to write a letter to god
but then is that the same as just
praying
well let's talk about that for just a
second uh when paul says
in romans i'm sorry for second
corinthians chapter three
he said uh i'll start with verse two you
are our epistle now the word epistle
means letter and i think you know that
written in our hearts known and read by
all men paul is saying to the church
members you know uh the change in your
life is seen by all men you are the
epistle that we wrote through the words
that we speak they've been written in
your heart and now people see the change
in your life and then he says in verse
three clearly you are an epistle of
christ ministered by us
written not with ink but by the spirit
of the living god not on tables of stone
but on the tablets of flesh that is on
the heart
you can read where it says in
ecclesiastes and in jeremiah and in
hebrews chapter 8 that the new covenant
is written
he says i'll take the stony heart out of
your flesh and i'll give you a heart of
flesh and the new covenant is written on
our hearts
and the word of god is written on our
hearts and that changes our lives our
lives are now guided by the word and not
by a letter written in stone and so i
think that's what paul is emphasizing
here you want to add anything to that
yeah not that it's wrong to to write
down your thoughts
maybe even write down a prayer you have
the psalms many of which are prayers
that were written down
but god doesn't need us to write down
our prayers we can pray and god can hear
and he will answer but sometimes it is
helpful to kind of organize our thoughts
and write them down but i think this
verse pastor as you mentioned this is a
living letter where we're example of
christ's grace to those around us they
can see allies have been changed and
it's a testimony or a witness and i
think that is the primary reference here
that paul is making
yep very good hey thank you martin
appreciate that call we've got david
listening in new york david welcome to
the program
hi how you doing um
i'm puzzled by
romans 10 4 where it says christ is the
end of the law what does exactly does
that mean
yeah now when you say law in the jewish
mind there were several categories of
law
there were a number of ceremonial laws
that started when god called the hebrew
nation
and for instance the law about
circumcision
sacrificing lambs in the temple
the priesthood
the bible tells us that when jesus died
on the cross
that the veil in the temple was ripped
from top to bottom because now
it's not a physical temple it's uh the
church god's people are a living temple
and tells us the high priests rent his
robes and it's not the earthly levitical
high priest
anymore now the bible says we're a
nation of kings and priests
and so
all the ceremonial laws have been done
away with
the law is about keeping the annual
sabbath and the feast days and the
things that had to do with the sanctuary
christ is our passover lamb
it's not saying the ten commandments are
done away with because
that's a law that god spoke with his
voice he wrote with his own finger he
wrote it in stone it's a very different
nature
clearly it is still wrong to murder to
lie to commit adultery to use god's name
in vain so forth and so uh it's talking
about jesus was the fulfillment of all
these ceremonial laws that were shadows
that pointed to him
you know also if you look at the verse
just ahead verse three it talks about a
group of people who were trying to
obtain righteousness by their works it
says in seeking to establish their own
righteousness if not submitted to the
righteousness of god then it says christ
is the end of the law for righteousness
so here it's talking about how do we
obtain the righteousness that is needed
for entry into heaven it's not the
result of works it comes by faith in
jesus and then i think he goes on to
explain it even further and that faith
in christ should be manifest in the way
a person lives our life should reflect
the fact that we are committed to christ
and so that's not taken away from holy
living or others telling us how one
ought to live by receiving christ right
and paul has this debate uh often in
galatians and the big debate there in
galatians was over circumcision in
particular he's saying you know that's
not the that's not the avenue to
righteousness
thank you very much david hope that
helps we've got paul listening in
indiana paul welcome to the program
thank you can you hear me yes loud and
clear
all right i have a question about
judgment specifically in matthew 19 28.
the you know the old testament and
throughout the bible it talks about god
judging and or god judging through jesus
um you know deuteronomy ezekiel romans
acts but in matthew and and in
revelation 20 verse 4
it talks about judgment given over to
the saints or to some others that sit on
the throne so i just wonder you know
what what you thought about that
yeah and keep in mind uh judging in the
bible did not always mean the way we
think of a judge where
they sit down and you've got them there
they got their wooden gavel and they're
going innocent guilty i find you guilty
guilty innocent
uh there were judges in bible times
that would they were supposed to exalt
god and you've got the
roughly 12 judges if you include samuel
i think you know samson was a judge and
talks about
deborah and barrack and these different
judges
they were leaders and so when it talks
about the 12 apostles sitting on 12
thrones judging they were not like
different circuit courts that were you
know dealing with dmv speeding tickets
and so
some of the judgment you read about in
revelation chapter 20 is talking about a
judgment where the redeemed or
evaluating the judgments of god
uh and they may even be you know
affirming that god is righteous in
not giving those fallen angels another
chance that they're going to go to the
lake of fire
but um
i think here we talk about the 12
apostles you'll be judging the 12th he's
saying through eternity they're going to
be enthroned
they're going to be in positions of
glorifying god and leadership
but it won't be judgment the way we
think of it here on earth
okay
i appreciate it thank you all right
thanks so much
we've got brian listening in michigan
brian you're on bible answers live
hello thank you for taking my call yeah
thanks for calling um i've got a
question here i
i've always been culturally god all my
life but
i got a little say arrogant about it and
over i just realized all of a sudden
about two or three months ago i saw my
sins through somebody else's eyes and
realized i've been spending the last 20
years
pretty much living in sin
so i straightened my life out i cut out
all media i just really got down to just
focusing on christ listening to sermons
instead of watching movies and one of
the sermons that's popped up one of the
things popped up three or four times is
doug batcher where he says that grieving
the holy spirit
and then he says
there's some in the bible that didn't
even know they lost it so now also i'm
in fear because there's nothing more
scary to me than separation from god how
do i know if i grieve the holy spirit
away from myself or not
well based on what you're telling me
you've got conviction of sin i think
people when they grieved away the holy
spirit they don't even have that gift of
conviction
the other thing is you're you're making
reforms it sounds like the spirit's
working in your life to turn away from
what is evil and and to draw near to god
and that's that's the holy spirit that
draws you
so you know i'm i'm not your judge but i
would
i would guess from the fruit of what
you're telling me that you still have an
interest in god and
one thing you said did kind of trigger a
concern for me you said i'm
straightening myself out i think i know
what you mean by that and you're you're
trying to make practical changes in your
life but ultimately uh you we really
need to trust god to
transform us
that's one thing that went through my
mind is
you know would i even be able to do this
on my own anyways
and that just came into my head before i
called you go wait a minute if i'm
making these changes am i making them or
you know can i even do that on my own or
is the holy spirit doing this and that's
what i can look at i don't know it
sounds like the spirit of god's working
in your mind right now i mean
i i wouldn't worry about that um i mean
you know i shouldn't say you should
never worry about grieving away the holy
spirit but i don't think that that's
something you've done based on what
you're sharing i think you for that i
that's i just you know um it's a hard
life and there's so much distractions
out there it is getting tougher but when
i was 40 years old i'm 58 when i was 40
i
i was a sabbath keeper since i was six
raising a sunday church and then when i
turned 40 i realized i just wasted my
life i've been doing sports athletics
all stuff no girlfriend for like 20
years and all sudden i've got on my ease
i prayed and god answered my prayer with
a wife on the other side of the world
from the philippines and yeah she's been
working on my life too and um that's how
i got found you and i am thankful for
you to be there because you have taught
me a lot i gotta thank you for that
before i let you go well that's okay i
sure appreciate that thanks so much
brian and we do have a book
talks about uh the holy spirit that's
right and grieving away the holy spirit
what that means we've got the book it's
entitled i'm thinking we have several
pastor dog we have one that's called
life in the spirit that talks about uh
the power of the holy spirit
transforming somebody's life and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks the number to call for
that is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book called life
in the spirit we'll be happy to send it
to you we also have a book talking about
the unpardonable sin i think it's called
um point of no return yes
it's actually an encouraging book but it
says what is and what is not grieving
away the holy spirit and we'll also be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks we've got rachel listening in
arizona rachel welcome to the program
hi good evening hi
hi um my question is concerning
revelation 18 23
um do you want to read it first or sure
it says and the light of a candle should
shine no more at all in the and the
voice of the bridegroom and of the bride
shall be heard no more at all in thee
for thy merchants were the great men of
the earth for by them thy sorceries by
uh for by thy sorceries were all nations
deceived
right and so um
so the question
is concerning um
the word pharmic pharma kia pharmakia
yeah that's sorceries that's where we
get the word pharmacy
yes
so the question is could revelation 18
chapter 18 be referring to how the world
will attempt to solve the plagues in the
last days through pharmaceuticals
you know i've not thought of that i i
have
i have thought because
sorcerers used to use drugs
and i have thought we are living in a
time where there's a lot of drug abuse
and um
that you know the devil has he snared so
many people with addictions to alcohol
and
opioids and uh heroin and you name it
you know crack and meth and
yeah this
a lot of people have been deceived
by drugs
i was in that generation where we were
all taking hallucinogenics i don't
hesitate telling people this because
they think i'm still having a flashback
when i preach
but uh i was in that generation where we
were taking mushrooms and
hallucinogenics trying to find god and
it was a big deception
all you found is really confusion
but that's pharmacia you know
sorceries
and i think in the in the context here
is talking about the fall of babylon we
know that there are
a number of false christs in the last
days there will be false miracles
and that'll actually be used by the
devil to gather and galvanize support
for his false claims at the end of time
so there's also a reference to that here
in in this passage in revelation 18.
yeah thank you rachel
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible-related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time call us at 1 800
god says
[Music]
next holder that we have is isaac from
arizona hi zach welcome to the program
oh hello hi how do you know if you've
written the lamb's book of life
well
the bible tells us that if we accept
the provision that jesus has made
through his sacrifice i should say the
provision that god the father made in
giving his son
that when we accept that covenant
and we ask god to forgive our sins and
we repent of our sins confess our sins
and that we with our hearts
take up our cross and say lord we want
to follow you
if we're baptized
i believe then it's our names it's a
covenant we're making with god that our
names are entered into the to the book
of life
and um
that we've just got that promise
in in revelation it also talks about the
names being in the book of life in uh
one of the churches he said if
if you don't repent i'll take your name
out of the bible
so it must be in the book of life for
church members right well we have that
verse and i find it here in first john 1
verse 9 it says if we confess our sins
he's faithful and just to forgive us and
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness
so heartfelt confession just coming to
god acknowledging our need of a savior
confessing our sins that gets the name
written in the lamb's book of life but
we want to make sure it stays in the
lamb's book of life and that's why paul
says i die daily it's a a day by day
surrendering of self to christ you know
we do have a book past today it's called
three steps to heaven and i think it'll
cover these very important questions how
do we get our name in the lamb's book of
life how do we keep it in the last book
of life we'll be happy to send that book
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
three steps to heaven well get in the
mail if you're outside of north america
you can read the book for free online at
the amazing facts website
next quarter that we have is damon
listening from oklahoma city oklahoma
damon welcome to the program hey how you
guys doing good thanks for calling oh
thanks um so i had a question about the
virgin birth i seen a debate online and
they were going back and forth whether
it was the holy spirit of joseph
and the people who were arguing joseph
used um two two verses and i want to
know what you guys thought about it
um they used second samuel 17 12
and then first chronicles 17 11. all
right well let's read second samuel 17
12 so we shall come upon him in some
place where he shall be found and we
will light upon him as the dew falls
upon the ground and him and all the men
that are with him
and there shall not be left so much as
one is that what you're talking about uh
no
the second samuel 17 12 i believe you
sure wasn't first samuel 17 12.
i just read second samuel oh 1712. i i
apologize i read sec second samuel 17 2
1712 let me go here
you know that is
1712. uh i did it may have been tuesday
all right let's try let's try first
samuel 17 12 and let's see if that hits
the jackpot
so david was the son of the ephrathite
that bethlehem judea whose name was
jesse
and he had eight sons and the man went
among them for an old man in the days of
saul
and then you're talking about the other
verse where it says that david was among
uh seven brothers
uh no i must have got the verse wrong i
thought it was uh what about let's try
first chronicles 17 11 because i think
that's another one
yeah i got the verse right here let me
read that while you turn to that passage
it says in the shall be when your days
are fulfilled you must go to be with
your fathers and i will set up your seed
after you and will be of your sons and
i'll establish his kingdom
so i was probably talking about the
lineage
of christ so you said people were
arguing they were using these verses and
they were arguing about the the divinity
of joseph or whether it was through
david well no the virgin birth they were
saying that the verses were saying that
it was joseph who were actually the one
who got it on mary impregnated not the
holy spirit well you know the bible
tells us if you read in luke it traces
the genealogy of jesus through mary's
father
and so
mary was also a
child a descendant of david
as well as joseph but uh let me give you
something to think about
the bible tells us that the conception
was of the holy spirit right
and so if the conception is of the holy
spirit it doesn't mean that god had some
intimate relationship with mary per se
do you know that
a man can have his seed taken from him
and he can
it can be transported and inseminate
someone on the other side of the planet
it's called artificial insemination
and so
i spoke to a rabbi once why he actually
was a jewish christian
and he said yeah i've read there in the
new testament where it says that mary
was conceived of the holy spirit but
jesus is the son of joseph
god took a seed from joseph and filled
it with the holy spirit and impregnated
mary with joseph seed so what would have
prevented god from doing that i really
didn't have a good answer for him
because it could have happened that way
we know that jesus there's something
supernatural about him
but
so i think that that verse there's a lot
of latitude in there but we just know
that mary was a virgin the bible is very
clear about that
it was a virgin birth
and you he the bible even quotes in
matthew behold a virgin will conceive
and bring forth a son so there's no
question about that
but if humans can artificially
inseminate a person why would we think
that god can't well and i was thinking
that also like how can
i don't know if this is a valid point
but um how can joseph he's a man
you know
create jesus who's god
you know a mortal man right well and i
don't think it happened that way i think
that jesus uh there was something
definitely supernatural about christ
and his birth is one example of that but
he was 100 human so the bible refers to
this as the mystery of godliness how god
became a man the incarnation is a great
mystery for us
i don't think science can explain it and
we're sort of we're you know tiptoeing
around
the unknown when we try to explain that
and you know if somebody's going to
believe the bible there's little doubt
if you're looking first
luke chapter 1 verse 35
this is the angel speaking he makes it
very clear he says the holy spirit will
come upon you the angel is talking to
mary and the power of the highest will
overshadow you also that holy one who is
born of you will be called the son of
god so you can't really get about or get
around that this was directly the result
of the holy spirit doing a miraculous
work
in mary
so hey we thank you very much damon hope
that helps a little bit
talking about the incarnation
we've got michaela listening in
massachusetts michaela welcome to the
program hi pastor thank you so much my
question is should christians invest in
the stock market um well you know
there's no verse uh per se on the stock
market but jesus does share a parable
where and i forget where that is in
matthew john where uh the parable of the
talents where jesus said
this is unfaithful servant and he takes
his master's money and he buries it and
master comes back he gives it back to
him and the master said you wicked and
lazy servant you should have at least
invested it with a banker so i could
have got my interest
well what bankers do is they invest in
the stocks
and so jesus said you know if you invest
in companies that over time are shown to
do better than a regular
you know small investment of a bank our
mutual fund is basically getting a fund
of stocks there's nothing wrong with
investing in companies
now
i personally i invest a little bit in
the stock market i don't day trade
and i don't invest in tobacco companies
i don't invest in
disney or some some of these
entertainment companies that try and
invest in things that a christian can
morally say this sounds like a good
company they're doing any good work and
i'm going to invest in them
but um
so i don't know if that helps you at all
i don't think we ought to be gambling
where you're trying to day trade and
speculate
but when you put your money in the bank
what do you think the bank does
they invest in the stocks
yeah
okay thank you very much that's very
helpful next holder that we have is
vanessa listening from los angeles
vanessa welcome to the program hi thank
you for taking my question so my
questions regarding marriage okay um my
boyfriend and i have been together for a
long time are committed to each other
but our different christian religious
backgrounds and i just want to know how
we can go about a union before god so
that we can be married but you know
respecting each other's religious views
well you know what paul says
he he says you should not be unequally
yoked together
and
there there's a real problem if people
marry and they do not have they're not
united in their faith
now when you say you're of different
religious persuasions you mean different
denominations of christian or different
religions
yes different christian denomination
do you mind my asking how big the
difference is
um
i mean like if one of you is a methodist
and one of you is a baptist you'll have
problems but it won't be as bad if
one of you to jehovah witness and one of
these uh
latter-day saints so
well i was raised
and he was raised fda
um
but
you know i don't think you should get
married until you are in agreement about
your faith
because it really is a problem
when um
you know just in the example that you
just cited
uh you know if if you probably if you've
been dating for a while you know there's
some significant differences
yes
and and um
yeah even like if you have kids and you
say well what day we're going to go to
church you go you're going two different
days that'll wear them out
so
yeah you want to be of the same faith
you know i think this is a great
opportunity if two people are thinking
about getting married and of course that
is a very important decision
uh the least they could do is sit down
and study out what the other person
believes and just have an open and frank
bible study look at the differences and
ask which is closest to the word of god
sometimes we're going to go against
maybe our family background or the
tradition that has been prominent in our
household and and seek to know god's
will after all if you want god's
blessing on your marriage you want to
make sure that you're following the
bible as close as possible so there is
an opportunity for that and we encourage
you to do that vanessa find a
some good lessons amazing facts has some
lessons that'll actually help people go
through the bible and learn very
important bible principles and that's
for free at the amazing facts website
yes absolutely recommend that
and go through a set of studies together
and see if you guys can
you know it can two walk together unless
they're agreed and that's jesus and i
think jesus was quoting
hosea when he said that
but um thank you vanessa and do we have
no we don't have time for another
question oh listening friends we see
george and sylvia diana troy we did not
get your question tonight we hope you
give us another chance
friends
hope you'll go to the amazing facts
website you can study and listen all
week long amazingfacts.org
god willing we'll get together and study
his word again together next week
[Music]
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 pm
and 8 p.m pacific time to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
tune in next time for more bible answers
live honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
an international pandemic killing
thousands riots ripping communities
apart
a global economic implosion many are
wondering is this the end of the world
few question the military economic and
technological might of the united states
so if we really are facing the last days
if these worldwide catastrophes are
really harbingers of the end
shouldn't we expect the united states to
play a key role in the final events of
bible prophecy the book of revelation
provides unmistakable clues
and to help you understand them amazing
facts is releasing america in bible
prophecy
it's going to take you step by step in
identifying the global forces at work in
these last days
you might be surprised what the bible
really says you owe it to yourself to
find out so get yourself a copy of
america in bible prophecy
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
or call 1-800-538-7275
i grew up mostly in new york city i was
sent to
many different boarding schools most of
these schools told me that there was no
purpose in life
and i saw in my home people were not
very happy and i would think about
suicide sharing a personal testimony can
be one of the most powerful ways to win
souls to christ that's why i'd like to
invite you to discover and share a new
presentation of my richest caveman
testimony it's now available on a
special dvd from amazing facts we've
even included the award-winning kingdoms
in time documentary that recently aired
on the history channel to get your copy
of the richest caveman visit
afbookstore.com or call 800-538-7275
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california